To help you review for the second exam, we're going to look back now through
lesson 17 through 26, and the material we've covered during that time. Let's
get started. We begin by developing and understanding of functions. We ask the
question, what is a function? As you learned, a function pairs each input value
with exactly one output value. Which means we can figure out if a graph
represents a function by using the vertical line test. We then looked at domain
and range as well as explored what it means for a function to be either even or
odd. From there, we investigated the overall shape of a function. Going all the
way from minus infinity to infinity in the domain, looking at whether it's
increasing or decreasing, and whether it has maximum and minimum points. This
led to a discussion about finding real zeros, which, as you remember, are the x
coordinates of the graph's x intercepts. And we used a polynomial long division
to help us along the way. To help us narrow down the list of possible rational
zeroes for a polynomial function we used the Rational Zero Theorem. When we
couldn't find the exact values of zeroes that we could see on graphs, the
intermediate value theorem helped us approximate their locations. With
Piecewise Functions, we got to put together some really interesting graphs, and
start thinking more about domain and range. This prepared us to work with
rational functions, whose vertical, horizontal,and slant asymptotes restrict
their domains and ranges in particular ways. Lastly, we explored
Transformations of Functions. Rigid transformations include vertical and
horizontal shifts as well as reflections in the x and y axis. Nonrigid
transformations, on the other hand, distort the shape of functions by
stretching or shrinking them. We encourage you to review the practice problems
at the end of each lesson, the problem sets and the summary review videos. Best
of luck to you. We know you'll do well. [BLANK_AUDIO]